[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
Ireland Baldwin says her cousin Haley
Bieber and her husband Justin Bieber
could care less about the haters who
chanted Selena as they walked the red
carpet at the Met Gala I can't handle it
it all went down on Monday when the
lovebirds attended Fashion's biggest
night in New York City fans of Justin's
ex Selena Gomez were camped outside the
Metropolitan Museum of Art and when it
came time for the Beavers to walk the
carpet they started chanting Selena's
name
a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the moment was posted to tick tock and
Selena's fans can be heard loud and
clear he won't even hold her hand
well Ireland was having none of it and
swooped into the comments with a
laughing crying Emoji writing quote
they're one of the happiest and most in
love couples I've ever gotten the chance
to be around they don't care about them
and it appears she was right immediately
after all that chanting went down Justin
and Haley talked to Kiki Palmer for
Vogue and seemed A-Okay as I become more
of an adult I think things just start to
evolve and change and become more grown
up I think I'm married now so I think
things just become more
uh adult I guess of course Justin had an
on-again off-again romance with Selena
prior to and even following the first
time he dated Haley we have a good time
together
he's just really sweet he's a good kid
he's a good heart and uh I love him
after calling it off with Selena for
good he rekindled his relationship with
Haley and the two tied the knot in 2018.
they've gone through a lot of trial and
era as individuals and together and I
think that you know that's really what
withstands and what holds a relationship
and really proves its worth and that
it's meant to be you know and they've
proved it I think and there doesn't seem
to be any ill will between Selena and
Haley in fact Haley recently showed some
subtle support for the only murders in
the building Star by liking a post of
the singer's L magazine cover I love it
as for Ireland she's always been an
advocate for the Bieber's romance they
just bring out the good in each other
they really do they're very respectable
couple just check out what she told E.T
back in 2018 shortly after the couple
got engaged it was meant to be a long
time ago it was just a long time coming
and we're all like all right thank god
let's move forward now woo yeah totally
they're so in love and they really do a
lot of good for each other and that's
the most important thing for me is that
he makes her so happy and so connected
[Music]